après les allures de fin du monde à New
York
le filtre sépia semble se dissiper
prévient la gouverneur de l'État de New
York la qualité de l'air est encore
l'une des pires jamais enregistrées ce
matin la ville a distribué des masques
N95 au New Yorkais
même message de la part du maire de
Baltimore
l'agence fédérale américaine de la vie à
Sion en retardé certains volent en
raison de la piètre visibilité pour de
la fumée provenant de
la première fois que
je vois ce phénomène c'est peut-être
aussi inconvénient pour les gens qui
travaillent au sol les préposés aux
bagages le ravitaillement des avions en
nourriture carburant plusieurs
américains sont restés coincés dans les
aéroports comme la femme d'hyn qui doit
venir le rejoindre à Montréal
l'air était assez pollué sushi la
débarit il arrive d'une semaine de
vacances à Washington on a même reçu des
messages de ma famille en Inde qui sont
vraiment inquiets
près d'un barbecue dit
en arrivant à Montréal certains médias
américains blâmment le Canada comme la
une du New York Post ou encore Fox News
sert le même genre de commentaires
merci pour la fumée ironie style
de la majorité démocrate au Sénat
non thématique il faut agir à court et
long terme a-t-il dit le président Joe
Biden a justement annoncé l'envoi
d'avion citerne supplémentaires et le
déploiement de d'autres pompiers
américains rapidement ici Jacques Audrey
Charbonneau Radio-Canada Montréal